there's uh
unfortunately sadly a lot of people that
look up to you
that is a horrible thing but life is a
nightmare
yeah uh if you were to give them advice
young folks people in college maybe even
high school
but people in their 20s about what to do
with their life
uh whether it's career whether it's just
life in general what would you say
ignore everyone make a few good friends
truly have honest conversations with
yourself about
your what when do you feel the most
alive
figure that out when and how do you feel
the most
alive yeah figure that out
try to figure out a job or a career that
can replicate that feeling
um don't listen to anyone don't listen
to your parents
don't listen to the gurus on the
internet don't listen to me
don't listen to anyone figure out
you know where you feel the most alive
where do you feel excited
where do you where does your pulse
quicken what do you feel
matters when you're in a situation do
you feel like it matters
uh what situation was that what got you
excited
what thing did you walk into where you
looked around and were taken back and
you're like wow this is amazing and i'm
filled with awe
if you can figure out a life where you
you you can
excite yourself you might not use drugs
or alcohol or a sex addiction or
gambling or irresponsibility you might
not have to get your [ __ ]
kicks in very destructive places
if you can get them in a productive
place well you gotta you had a pretty
weaving life that's full of uh
mistakes and so on many mistakes
is that are mistakes a bugger feature
like do you recommend
uh embrace the mistakes like make a
bunch of them depends what they are
right so well you you've had the full
spectrum i've had a lot but a lot of
mine could have sunk
me right like they sound like fun when i
talk about them but they actually could
have
sunk me and they were all part of what
made me
funny but i don't know i would never
tell anyone else
to just light their life on fire and
hope it works out on the other end it
would be pretty irresponsible
but hey at the end of the day it's like
you're gonna we get there's you know
i think one of my themes is that there's
too much we give the power
we think we have to the power of choice
has been elevated on our society to uh
an unhealthy degree
i think people are i think you could you
could get really good at something but
you're born with a certain
aptitude it might be to be a deal maker
it might be to be an athlete it might be
to be an
artist it might mean to be a romantic
and just fall in and out of love in and
out of love internet love it might be to
be like a world traveler like
but whatever you are i think you are i
think that there's something about you
that makes you something
and if you can figure it out and then
refine you're not going to be good at it
per se
but if you're if you're an athlete it
might not mean that you're going to be a
great
athlete in the history but it might mean
you're the best coach anyone's ever had
or you're
the person that you know builds a local
scene for young athletes or whatever if
you are
a really good deal maker it doesn't mean
you're going to be warren buffett but it
might mean you're somebody who enjoys
making deals all the time and things
like that like
if you're an entertainer it might mean
that you are
an entertainer it might mean that you
are in the world of entertainment
because you love it so much
that if you lack the skill set to really
pursue it on a degree
you just want to be like there's there's
a there's a thing inside of you
that makes you what you are i think i
look at certain people and i go you were
born to be that thing
you know the whole purpose is to find it
i was a juror on that murder trial on a
murder trial in long island and the
the woman who's a d.a i'm like you were
born to do this you were born to
put murderers away and this guy killed
the the mother of his children and he's
a bad guy but like i was like you are
really good at what you do she has a
strong belief in whatever her
moral code is and what her justice and
ethics are and she wants to communicate
that to people she was very good
at at doing what she did i don't know
the facts of the case i didn't really
listen he seemed guilty so i just voted
guilty
but she i didn't really listen to her
but i heard the shape of her mouth was
very bovine like a cow and
it conferred a certain level of
expertise that i
enjoyed well it's funny i mean you could
see
you're half joking yeah you can often
that people just this they found their
place they found their roles found their
thing
they found their thing and that's kind
of the the purpose of life and once you
are in a in a place that seems sticky
like
the place that seems right you know
that's one of the problems with the
generation that you're speaking to
is there's always a feeling like i
should keep exploring keep exploring
but it's okay to stay in a place that
you found that works yeah and
listen sometimes the best place you'll
find is like one point people are like
when did you feel really excited and
alive it's like doing nothing
right you know like that's the other
thing it's like some people are gonna be
like i feel really excited and alive and
i'm laying in my backyard in a hammock
yeah and i just wanted the simplest life
and not have to do much and i don't like
doing anything
and i love laying around and going wow
this guy looks good today
yeah bill gates goes this guy's good
today let's shoot a missile into it
he wants to do [ __ ] right so it's like
in between that
and nothing is you can find something
but
in that process for you personally i
mean
for me and for others i think there's a
struggle when you look in the when tim
dylan looks in the mirror
do you love yourself do you hate
yourself well a lot of times i think i'm
amy schumer so i'm confused
i don't i'm a dayton to myself all the
time i don't love myself or hate myself
addicts have a very uh bad uh
problem where you can't just fall in
love with yourself and you can't hate
yourself
both of them lead you to a negative
place you try to stay kind of even keel
i don't go like hey man you put out a
video get all these views things are
great you sold a bunch of tickets let's
[ __ ] go out like maybe let's
hey man let's have that drink that
you've been waiting for for 11 years
and i don't look at myself and go you
ate a burger yesterday you're a piece of
[ __ ]
you're horrible you'll never you know
get into the shape you want like i try
not to get too low or too high both of
them are
not good for my particular mind
you